i want to tell you a story i have a
little bit of data but it's mostly a
story and mostly what i want to get is
is your expertise so the the simple part
of the story is that about a year and a
half ago i helped make a mooc and it led
me to realize that i could dramatically
transform the class that i regularly
teach i'd been teaching class about 15
years and there were sort of itchy
problems that had bothered me all these
years and i had no way to fix them all
until the mooc came along
so i want to tell you a little bit about
how the mooc made it possible what it
did what i did and what i and some of
those sort of students learned from that
and again it's supposed to be mostly
discussion so
my main goal
is to present some things to start a
conversation because it's clear you all
have a huge amount of experience and
what's also interesting is that people
have spots of experience we know little
bits and pieces and i think the neat
thing is we'll be able to put them
together so i'll try to say as little as
i can um just to provoke i hope an
interesting conversation
so the plan
is this there's three main things i want
to talk i want to have a conversation
about and now for each one i'll give an
introduction to set it up and then we'll
have some conversation and then we'll
get back and do a little introduction
set it up my introductions start longer
and then get shorter
we may not do all three of them i think
they're all worthy topics for discussion
i will have to run the balance between
cutting off discussion and and making
sure we say all the interesting things
so for each of these after i say
something these are just a place to get
started in terms of what more would you
want to know sounds like there's people
interested in that sort of question what
questions and issues does this raise in
terms of education and moocs and and
flipping classes and in the brick and
mortar classes and also what might
happen next and i'm sure you may even
have other ones but those are sort of
guiding questions
all right so i want to start with is a
tiny little bit these are so
my students
it's a first semester majors biology
course i've taught it for 15 years i try
to aim to cover less and have them
understand more the students are
slightly non-traditional when umass
boston is a commuter school and people
going back to school so they're not the
sort of exactly average freshman but
they're pretty similar mostly it has no
prerequisites
so i've been teaching you for about 15
years standard lecture and lab format
trying to be more interactive in lecture
but then this opportunity came along to
as i say flip the class and so just to
say sort of why i did it to start off
the part of the conversation is that
this right the goal of flipping the
class what is the goal of flipping class
the students should come to class
prepared right the thing is that's not a
new idea as people have been saying most
of the stuff is not actually amazingly
new that in fact in the humanities
people have been expecting that you read
moby dick before you came into class and
talked about movie day but for oddly in
the sciences we don't expect that people
have come to class prepared and so
the main mission was if it was going to
be less glib was to say that um
to do what is best done in the right
context so there's certain things that
are best done at home and certain things
that are best done in class thinking in
terms of various capabilities at home
the main thing is they have flexible
time right they have as much or as
little time as they need to get prepared
but i'm not around in class i have a
fixed time but i'm around and so you
want to try to divide up the labor in a
way that makes best use of those two
things and so reading watching videos
and doing warm-up problems are fantastic
things to do on your own just if you if
you get it quickly you can get it
quickly if you take a lot of time you
can take a lot of time it allows for
flexibility with students in class
there's we have this group of people
with a variety of different questions
and the same way you think about here
what's the point of bringing all these
people together having everybody fly in
here has a rather large carbon footprint
what do we get out of the group together
that we don't get
otherwise and so to make the best use of
that is these kind of activities that do
in class so that you discuss things you
can apply them you can fill in gaps and
you can have the students ask questions
and
to use the expertise of the instructor
and sometimes take some extent that your
classmates so these are
what they've been calling active
learning and people have different
levels of familiarity with that
terminology i want to in a minute sort
of make it clear what i mean by that but
um what the having the mooc content
online allowed me to do was it left time
in class to do these more active things
which i'll come back to in
in a little bit
so again the key was the mooc by moving
a lot of the lectures off into
cyberspace and before class then rather
than in class it freed up time to do
other things
and so let me be clear about what i had
them do online and then we'll talk about
what happened in class
so the there was i think an important
distinction so my
class was based on the seven double ox
mooc an edx mooc and that was organized
for no particularly good reason
like a regular class it was weekly units
with a couple of lectures and a problem
set and every once in a while it was an
exam that's just the way classes always
work at mit so that's they sort of
cloned that
because i want these as preparation for
every lecture right not lecture but for
every class session i had to re-slice
them they're not weekly units they're
daily units
the other thing is the problems are
there to get you thinking about the
material before you come in all right i
don't actually necessarily expect that
you'll have god at all
and i don't expect so i really all i
want is that you have a thought about it
some before you come into class and so
that we can fix any place any places
there are trouble so the assessment
these don't these are not the more the
problems and the problem sets become
less assessments and um or for summative
assessments and more formative
assessments to for the students in
practice and yeah yeah just the the
second bullet the lectures should that
be ungraded
so in the mooc they were graded
yeah you had to get them right right so
the in the seven double o makes x mook
it was all the questions that were ever
asked you had to get them right to get
credit for the course right right and so
i relaxed that for the for the spark
right
questions about that
let me clear what the so the distinction
between the two
and i make the argument that actually
it's quite difficult to make a single
online thing that does both because you
really think differently about the way
you organize the content and also you
think differently about the questions
the questions are to get people to think
about what they're doing
and prepare them to come into class and
use it rather than necessarily find out
whether they got it or not all right
yeah sure design
weekly units versus
is it because you have the lecture
every day
so yeah so um i should say that a bit
more precisely the spark units were sort
of a weeks like like we covered genetics
or something in three lectures and there
was a genetics problem set
with the daily units the way it is it'll
be like day one of genetics this is a
lecture to watch and then we have some
day one genetics activities and then we
have day two genetics activities so we
it's a finer scale instead of sort of 15
or 10 units it's like 30 units yeah
did you take the
materials
so i took them in the nx platform this
they were they were not they allowed me
to re-slice them so i got basically took
the seven double or x course the linga
would be i put it in studio which is a
edx's editing thingy and then i
rearranged it
no not engine no because edx seemed to
work be sort of it was easier to just do
it to put in the edx platform yeah
yeah so
when you say daily units you mean that
matched up with the days that you were
going to be teaching in class not like
seven days a week oh my goodness yes
yeah yeah i'm sorry and so so
so i should say i don't know how to say
this one class worths
of materials
exactly that would be a smarter way to
say it right thank you
right right all right
um
all right and so for what it's worth uh
oh let me actually show the next slide
so again to try to be a little bit try
to be a little bit clearer so for one
session so this would be a wednesday
right we were going to talk about parts
of genetics so there was a lecture to
watch which had embedded test yourself
questions right so there's these are
questions very simple questions there
were some optional reading there were
some warm-up problems again these in my
context you they were low stakes you
were just trying to make sure that uh
people had at least thought about the
material for they came to class and then
there were some things for after the
class some books of practice problems um
some
even some little some little um like
tutorial sessions and the like all right
so that before class you saw the lecture
you answered a bunch of questions and
you had at least thought about it before
you came in
and um
right
so what i what i want to do next is
again so what this because all this
monster amount of content used to be
what i spent my time on and now that was
happening before class i had all this
time opened up in class so what do you
do with that class right
so again it left me time for active
learning and there's many different
flavors of active learning
i used actually a relatively rudimentary
one um and what i was going to do i was
have distribute clickers to you guys i
don't know how familiar i was asking a
question so i'm going to have people
click and answer to show you what i mean
by this because i know some people know
about this and some people don't so what
we'll do we'll simulate clickers which
in a way i think might actually work
better so um in what clickers are
well actually you know what i'll ask the
next question we'll
stand so a is one finger you should pick
carefully uh two is is two fingers the c
i'm sorry a is one finger b is two c is
three d is four fingers so if you would
just hold up your hand with uh
where you're at in terms of
if you don't know it would be a be a one
all right so there's a mix of things all
right so the advantage of clickers is
each of you guys if you don't so that's
actually most people have heard of it
for those of you who haven't what you
would have in your hand is a little
looks like a tv remote control with five
buttons on it abcde
you would beam in your answer and
running up in the corner there would be
a time clock and a tally of how many
answers came in and when i finally when
i said okay we're all done i would hit a
button and we'd see a little bar graph
of how many people gave each answer
right
and that has several important things
but i want to do a sort of better
demonstration of that in a second so
again just to be clear about the kinds
of things i did in class right so i
wanted i'm a biologist i wanted to pick
a topic that i took a guess that many
people would have would be at least sort
of familiar with and so it was a sort of
web-based thing so imagine you had all
as your assignment watched a lecture
about how
html which is language of the web how
those tags work and rather than
lecturing about that you guys saw that
lecture so we come into class and i
would ask you a question like this and
the way html just a very brief thing
html tags that says underline that says
stop underlining all right so
there's many ways to do this but rather
than explaining it right are you have
you the the where's the the canonical
way to implement this is have everybody
vote beam in an answer without talking
to your neighbor commit to an answer
right
and then talk to your neighbor and then
vote again for time purposes let's just
do the the finger thing right so you
tell me if
that little you in the bracket starts
the underlining and then you on the
slash ends the underlining which is the
um which is the right answer from all of
those and i mean you can raise your hand
when you put up
um e i don't e i don't oh it's none of
the oh oh uh all right
oh it's none of them did i get it wrong
all right
i
did w
you're right you're right so that was
actually meant to start discussion no
the the um
so yes all right so that i think we can
that simulation has now made its point
so the um the
well so actually there's
well i'll stay out of that particular
place but the um
what this gives you is two things if
especially if you had clickers rather
than fingers is feedback you immediately
know because i'm going to tell you the
right answer i was aiming for b
forgetting about the capital w all right
it gives you feedback whether you got it
right also where you stand relative to
your peers it gives me great feedback
about where people stand right so if i
need to do some at this point i could do
more explaining if lots of people got it
wrong
um if most people get it right i can
move on do more questions like this
the students find it nice because like
typically they get it right and then
they know that they're doing well
it also provides anonymity right in this
room it's probably not nearly as a big
deal but nobody wants to be the one with
two fingers up when everybody else has
got five right that's that's real that's
very socially unacceptable and notably
raising your hand for yes or no you do
not want to be that one person with your
hand up in the room with everybody else
is their hand down so it provides the
students with anonymity
and me with feedback and
in my class i give you get credit
whether you get it right or wrong
basically i want people to think about
it and so that's
a simple sort of effective tool for this
and just to so that is what we spent
time in class doing instead of listening
to me lecture right
series of questions like that
um
i won't say much this was uh the the
earlier speaker talked about this in
detail there's a strong evidence that
this really works um so i will skip
ahead of that um
so
i will not say much about that so the
question so i've been saying that
using the spock the mooc to put on the
line
freed up timing class well so how much
time did it free up so um
there we go
so
these are two uh
we took some video of class and over the
semester we logged the percentage of
time spent lecturing and the blue or
different flavors of questions you use
it one instructor used the clickers and
one didn't traditional two is me
traditional one is somebody else's you
see most of the time i spent lecturing
all right um
and there was a little bit of q a this
is sort of what i was able to squeeze in
bit by bit year after year all right so
but mine those are pretty similar so my
question is is another way you can do is
sort of use clicker questions for
whatever i'm sort of a big fan of them
is you can
use there's not a right answer to this
question but you can sort of provoke
discussion right so you tell me think
about it for a second where would you
might you weigh in how low can you go i
was at 65 70 percent
lecture how low could you but imagining
you're trying to implement a class
how low in terms of lecture percentage
could you imagine going and still sort
of have it function
roughly speaking so give me your do your
the finger thing and see where you stand
so there's 10 percent a lot of twos and
threes it looks like so yeah so in that
neighborhood all right
because you've got it there's presumably
some explaining that you've got to do
and so well i can show you the data
um
from my class
is it came out like this that um that
it's sort of 25 was and that part of it
is as a teacher i can't resist blabbing
but i but in the end there's a certain
amount of
filling in the gaps when it's clear that
they didn't get stuff there's a certain
amount of wrapping up conclusions
because the time we count in the clicker
questions the time it takes to introduce
it and to to to answer it but if you
need further lecture to explain then
that that was kind of in there and so
um
it
it dramatically changed the time
allocation in the class all right um
in terms of evaluation i have a tiny
little bit of data so what are the can
tell you what the students thought
i asked them
you guys have taken a semester you guys
have taken lots of classes you've seen
probably been in chemistry which is
taught conventionally in my class we
should talk with a spock what would you
what should i do next year and they sort
of buy the definitely spock is 10
10-fold higher than definitely
conventional the trend is that they they
really loved it so that i had expected
resistance but they particularly liked
it
um
if you look at why they liked it i think
it's sort of instructive um we're some
grad students in my lab are trying to
tally this up a little bit more detail
this was just a sort of quickie
but you can group these in different
things
in terms of what people mentioned they
really liked this online lecture
business
and this caused me to think a lot about
it because i'm used to
thinking that my lectures are super
vital
and at least that the online lectures
are a poor substitute but the answer is
they're fantastic they can be better
than the real than me live because they
can stop and fast forward and go back to
the equivalent of saying can you say
that again can you say it again can you
skip over that boring part and eric can
ask for a different part than melanie
would right and and so that gives them
the flexibility and not only at their
own pace but on their own time whenever
they when they when they have time to do
it they like the problems as well that
were embedded both the rapid feedback
and the questions right and this gets to
the same idea the idea of active
learning which is that
this the notion of active learning is
after you pick something up you read
something you hear something you use it
in some way you exercise it and that
that helps them to learn and they
recognize it
and that also that the one awning class
was something that they was they found
were was productive and the last thing i
want to say before i want to get very
have a conversation
is um
is the grades and so i was able to give
the same final exam one year before and
the year i flipped the class and the
difference is not significant and my
first thing was oh you know i'm supposed
to show an improvement why did i go
through all this trouble if i don't get
an improvement and there's a couple
things um one is they did just i didn't
as you see i lectured one third as much
i essentially to a first approximation
gave no lectures on that material and
they did just fine okay which is i think
an important point second thing is in
blue is a course that i've been shining
up for 15 years and in purpose of course
was the very first time and my mission
the first time out was to get the plane
off the ground fly it straight and land
it without blowing up in midair and we
managed to do that so my sense is that
with that
only place to go from here is up
although again that that would be
conjecture
all right so
that phase one this sort of changes to
the class what questions do you have
what yeah josh
incentive
to do this like
money time off
i don't know no i didn't think about
like instructional design now for teams
how can you do all this stuff to
transform your course and make this
wrong so
no that there was a huge team to make
the spa to make the mooc the
transformation i did on myself
i am a sort of unrepentant nerd i just
like to do that kind of thing and i have
space that my teaching load is such that
and my research responsibilities are
such that i have the time to do
something like this
i know that's the thing well see well
that goes to
my last question which is about
dissemination
but could someone use what i've done
right without having to redo it but i
don't know that that but
yeah
i mean as i said when we were doing our
introductions i i teach a faculty
development
webinar i mean it's a webinar we have 24
campuses i get about 50 people every
time we do it um once a semester
and it's an i mean it's not rocket
science the move part was yes but
and i always tell faculty take baby
steps anyways i mean ease yourself into
this we give them the basics and you
know there are people certainly on
campus available for consultation our
teaching and learning center and so
forth but it's not the kind of
of um they usually don't need the kind
of major involvement from learning
designers and others as they do when
we're developing a fully online course
or a mooc
well and also
i made my job harder because
my contribution to the mooc was a whole
bunch of software simulations that i had
developed which were a real pain to
build in if i had just been doing sort
of your classic multiple choice
questions and videos which actually you
can get a ton of mileage out of
especially if your goal is not to teach
all this but just to set people up for
class
then um
it would have been a lot easier
other things
yeah
how did you introduce the content like
how did you frame it was any
face-to-face time used to set that up or
was it just go watch someone else's
lectures and the reason i'm asking is
because i think earlier today in david
pritchard's other research section he
alluded to
an experiment he had done in his class
so separately where he found that
watching the lectures and then coming to
class and doing more
sort of active problems together
he was not seeing as much learning and i
wondered
like
what
well how was the content being framed
but were people just being told like go
watch lectures go read the book or
whatever were they not as excited i
don't know so i made you wonder how did
you roll this out to students so what i
told them was so the quest those warm-up
questions and like my lectures at noon
they were all due at 11. so you had so
for every day there were some questions
that would do it eleven and so the and i
told but i just said the the spock is
here it's the material it's what you
need to do to get prepared you need to
get these points from these questions
that's that so i didn't frame it any
more than that either
from the university of
switzerland and we are not a front
runner in moocs but we did that pilot
move a year ago
and the experience of the teacher and
reporting here is that he separated in
the online class he just put the theory
and maybe a simulation or something and
some questions and in the classroom he
took the examples and the cases and
i made
people working on this and with this
strict separation he had to work over
his whole teaching materials of course
but the effect was
that now he has not to do much input
in the online environment anymore
because what he is actualizing is the
examples and the applied application
cases
i mean you're just it's it's the
scalable thing is tricky although for
whatever once you do it once i've done
it i can run it again and again but the
question is
if someone wanted to do it in biology
they could steal my stuff
but if or take it i mean we would be
theft but if someone wanted to do it in
chemistry they'd have to yeah they'd
have to roll their own presumably right
yeah well the other thing i should add
is we also point them um
you know to all the how-to stuff for our
lms
because that's a lot i mean we're not
telling them
oh go create simulations or whatever you
know we're like okay you can do quizzes
you can do something and we've got a lot
of in-the-can
self-help kind of how to set that up and
most of our faculty are more familiar
with that so i
probably made it sound like in one hour
we don't do all that
how about other sorts of things that
this raises um besides those
yeah michael
it seems that you freed up some time
to now have say deeper discussions about
the material but i was wondering if you
also considered um
using that free time for say
having them solve problems together in
groups
of the class so
the there are many more active things
that people could do there are case
studies and a variety of things i i took
a sort of low tech approach again just
so just sort of the first time out
typically what i would have them do is i
put up the question and have them
discuss as a group in little you know
not formal groups but with your
neighbors before we beamed in an answer
but yes you could certainly do more
things like that and
as as a time passes i can add those
things in right
other things yeah
how much of the online interactions for
example discussion
forums if there are any uh and for
example how many times have the student
got the question wrong how much of that
information to be used to inform you
face to face
oh yeah that's a very interesting
question i actually did none um
they were partly because i was so busy
redoing what i was going to be doing in
class and i was typically doing it more
or less at the last minute that i didn't
have time
also
as you'll see in a minute i want to talk
about i'm going to save some time for
this
because of the way the questions were
set up everyone got them right
so they didn't give me any useful
information so there was it turned so
that but i'll talk to you about that i
want to make sure to talk about that in
a second but let me make sure that then
erlang you had a question um
a couple questions one two
and this gets into our previous uh
address that we had
did you have to pay
for to license the miu mit
at all right so
again so maybe i should be careful about
what i'm a paradigm for uh because josh
will give me the evil eye for this one
too because
and rightfully so i have a sort of
special relationship with edx i don't
actually know what it is i think i'm
sort of a friend of the family right and
so because was because umass has not
ever paid them any money but i helped
them with uh and actually
mit paid me when i worked on the mooc so
i don't they are extremely nice to me uh
and i and and but but no so that so if
another person wanted to do this i don't
exactly know how that would work right
right eric does it sort of set up a
model and this goes to the
effort to take it again so there was the
original mooc and then now there's now
your version
you could imagine again with respect to
the previous talk and open in an open
environment where people just sort of
make different forks of this could you
imagine a place where you know maybe
then each as it sort of forks maybe
three or four times from there maybe
there's different branches of it that
people use in different kinds of ways
and large classes small classes computer
residential
and do you sort of see that as a
possibility oh i think that would be a
super idea if you could do such a i mean
there's all the licensing stuff but but
the openstax textbook people are trying
to do that with textbooks is that that
people can make their own fork of the
textbook and what i thought would be
actually even cooler
is if he could somehow graphically
represent that because if for example i
noticed that someone has taken a fork of
my course and like 10 000 people are
using it then i might want to look at
what they did right or if i've made a
fork of the textbook or the mooc and 10
000 people using mine i could tell that
to my chairman you know
at time to get a raise or whatever you
know so so the the there's there's lots
of neat things about that um
right
all right yeah erlang
are the lecturers
yes ish
so some days eric would get on a roll
and would run over um and and they're
what they are it's typically snipped up
into
five to 15 minute sections with a
question you know with a little question
embedded right right
all right let me go on oh yeah
sure it wasn't you who was appearing
there was there any sort of
how did your students
perceive that as opposed to seeing
you there's actually some interesting
data i want to talk about the next sect
that's a good segue into what i want to
say next because it turns out to be sort
of surprising um all right
so
what i want to talk about now are sort
of there are lots of things i learned
there were two things that are
intertwined that it was really important
to integrate all the pieces all right
and actually that's what i'm spending
this summer is basically really making
sure that integration works because it
didn't work as well it should and that
low stakes ungraded questions as is a
thing that i said a little bit about but
i want to say more about because i think
it turned out to be really interesting
so i'll say a little bit about them and
then we can have more of a conversation
about that too
so
this is
not in this is some data that i took i
surveyed the end of the semester ask
people to rate on it sort of zero to
three scale
um how useful were the following things
in preparing for the exams and there's a
couple of take-home messages from this
one is that they generally found most
things useful which is was pleasing
um
these are the warm-up and test yourself
questions are the ones that were right
in the mooc uh right embedded in the
lectures and this so they found them
useful because they were presumably
right at that time apropos and and write
available as they watched the lectures
there were some other ones that were
sort of external uh they're part of the
mooc but not nearly as much so and they
found them to be somewhat less useful
they liked the lectures and this goes to
eric's question so there were two there
are actually two kinds of lectures um
the ones in the spark were done by eric
lander and there were ones some by me
and because there were some of the
topics in this box some basic chemistry
that eric didn't cover that i needed to
cover and what's really interesting
about the comparison with the way they
found and i think this is important
so the production values were like night
and day the ones on edx are fantastic
they have a transcript that you can
click on it goes to the part of the
video they're filmed by a tv crew
good resolution they cut back and forth
to images this perfect audio is just
fantastic my lectures were with this
dreadful lecture capture system right so
it it captures it has a video of me
actually it's a video of the podium
which i never stand at okay and then
it's meant to do slide capture so my
lecture when i lecture when i write on a
tablet pc
and so it sort of randomly updates the
screen cap because it's waiting for a
slide and so what will happen is they'll
be i'll talk for 30 seconds then poof
all this writing will appear so it's
just horrible and awkward and needed a
special plug-in
but yet
they found them more useful
and i think that the message and when i
asked them why it was because i
delivered the goods right that is i know
what my students need and where they
have trouble
and i can tune it to them and not only
that i write the exam so it's a good
match to miss a better match to my
assessments than someone else's lectures
yeah josh
teaching is a relationship i know you
know you're right i i well see i
i
kept i felt ashamed of the poor
production values of my lectures and so
i assumed that it would be bad but
you're right i think that's true that
the that the integration of those my
expectations and those was was more
important than the video quality so that
i think was a big deal um they did like
i mean eric is a much more compelling
lecturer than i am but um
again it was the sort of match between
expectations and and um i mean what i
don't josh your question is interesting
what if it wasn't the other lectures
weren't bw but somebody else but was a
good match for content and that's
because there's two things you can't
separate there's the me that they know
the familiar guy as well as the one who
knows what they need so i don't know how
much is me and how much of it is what i
said i
were actually think conversation right
clearly you were having a conversation
with them when you're with them and when
you're online
although remember the
the lectures of mine you wouldn't have
seen me so it was just a sort of
disembodied voice
right so um
all right so let me
there's a little more let me say a
little the other the other thread in all
this were ungraded problems i was sort
of vague about that i want to be more
specific
this is a little edx terminology so you
had to get them right but after your
first try you could click what's called
the show answer button so you could see
the answer all right and so the mission
there was
what i've learned from my students is is
contrary to your sort of classic
business reward model the lower the
stakes the actually more thinking they
they do when you raise the stakes they
panic
and they get exam anxiety and they quit
thinking um also it was i didn't expect
that necessarily the lectures would
perfectly make it clear that they might
come into class with some questions so i
didn't really feel a
right to demand that they get them right
and i really want to bring home this
message
that they come to college thinking that
wrong answers are a failure when in fact
the whole message of moocs and my class
as well is that the wrongness is a
learning opportunity you get it wrong
you go back and watch the video again
and try it again so i want to give them
that chance
and so
again the like i said they they
they could just click through to the
answer if they wanted and in fact that
was the risk that they would slack off
when you lower the stakes right that
they could and that they might in fact
learn that that says potential course
collapse the thing that i feared in last
september was
that very soon they would learn you
could skip the lecture
click any random answer click show
answer entered in and come to class and
you got all the credit you needed and
then i'd come to class not prepared they
wouldn't get my clicker questions right
i'd have to lecture then we'd get behind
and then it would be sort of game over
and so
i was worried about that and the answer
that didn't happen but it almost
happened
and so the key to understanding this
business i want to show you a little bit
of our data too
is um and it goes to zionist question
because of that way it's wired up i
could not use whether they got the
questions right or wrong as any kind of
metric because essentially 90 of the
students got them correct if they tried
them they got them right so everybody
got them right the real question is did
they get them right before they peaked
or did they peak before they got it
right and so it turns out you can look
at logs and so i thought i'd try this is
i thought was
uh one way to think about how to
introduce this idea so if imagine i
collected these log files this would
have been my last clicker question so
these time entries that loaded the
problem they submitted a wrong answer
they looked at the show answer and then
they submitted a correct answer that
same problem how would you
score that which of those five
categories and so again a's one b is two
you put up your fingers for what what
what bin would you put that student in
and that student's response to that
problem
so i got a four
some fours
fours
fours in general
all right
okay
so that's what i was that this this is a
person who peaked all right
it turns out this is actually simple
most students log entries are really
long and complicated and they involve
multiple submissions but that that's the
idea so we were able to differentiate
there were five cat or five flavors that
any student's response to question could
be sorted and these are all mutually
exclusive and exhaustive categories and
so you can graph them two different ways
you can graph them over the course of
this yeah sure
because they waited some between showing
and submitting it they waited some
number of seconds which means they maybe
thought that
right so there's a ton of nuance that
this does not capture right right
because we also tried analyzing how many
attempts they take but it turns out they
do weird things like after they get it
right they'll submit it again a couple
times and that counts as multiple
attempts and so it looks like they like
tried all over the place but really they
were just submitting the right answer
many times so yeah you're right it turns
out like any of these log entry things
there's a ton of nuance that's
interesting i
but i mean maybe they just went away and
did something else i know it went to
facebook i mean who knows what they were
doing and during those 24 seconds
right right or what a note
14 seconds
all right so you if you graph by um over
the semester so this is sort of problems
over the course of semester there's a
work of my grad student nicole um the
fraction of students on any given
question how they behave and what you
see is it fell off at the end and so
they did they were well behaved at the
beginning and they were less well
behaved at the end um and i and so that
this is the fraction of students getting
it right without peaking so the other
thing is the mirror images the fraction
peaking went way up at the end and if
you asked the material got harder it was
somewhat material dependent
um it was later in the semester
also this material is stuff that i've i
know how to support them in and this
material was stuff that i was new i
hadn't taught before i think this is an
extremely sensitive measure of when they
feel sort of over their head or over
their you know over the water's been
over there and in over their head that
they say ah either like oh i'm too busy
i'm just going to click through or oh
this is so confusing i'm going to click
through oh there's too many problems i'm
going to click through so sort of it
doesn't take much of an excuse so this
is really great for course development
right because i know i got to work here
to support there's also big holes in
here i got to figure out why they did
they they punted on these ones but also
things i can put in place to help them
not do that towards the end yeah
yes and so but then because if i imagine
peaking is bad then how do i try to put
supports in so that doesn't happen right
right yeah is there a performance on the
exam questions in
that subject matter oh my god that is my
next graph but let me let me talk about
that but before anyone's about this one
yeah
okay do you have a question i mean like
you know did spring break fall right i
gotta look i forget there are a number
of i think it's also people seeing
patterns that when they're not
unnecessary so i might have to look at
it more carefully there was also some
the more confusing lectures came in here
um
to offer a structure speaking where you
give them the cheat sheet so they have
to read something oh okay
so you you help them peak
but not like giving them the answer but
some hints towards the answer that's a
neat idea i mean so there's a one of the
things to think about here is a bunch of
different ways to deal with this
another way i thought of is that for
example if you peak you can get half or
three quarters or some fraction of the
credit so that you you piggy see it but
you get you get you still can recover
some points even though you repeat right
because you either have to read it right
i mean
if it requires reading and you will
understand it that's right and peaking
is not always necessarily bad i mean if
you really just click through sort of
mindlessly that's bad but if you peek
and thought about why they an answer was
because the sun peaking is not bad if
you peaked and thought about the answer
huh all right well you said thought
about it when you it's that business
coming to class prepared right so they
don't get i don't know why i got that
one wrong but now i got a question in my
head that's not necessarily bad right
right
yeah before adaptive hints were
supported in the platform and so like
for future use i mean that's
a whole different
if you get it wrong here's a run you get
a pin that helps direct you to the right
answer without
giving it away you're wrong
that would be that's that's another
that's in the way sort of what diana was
saying oh a slightly different wrinkle
that's another neat idea right
all right so the and with respect to um
the question it turns out there is a
correlation so like if you could instead
of classifying by problem you can
classify by student so each point here
is a student and along here is the
fraction the fraction of the problems
that they answered correctly before they
peaked and that's their exam score and
there is as in the education biz that's
actually pretty big um correlation um
still it's not fantastic but that
explains 16 of the variation in their
exam score so that it and i can't what i
cannot tell you because this is only a
correlation is that um
doing those questions diligently may
helped you to do well in the exams it
could also very well be that good
students do well on the exams and are
diligent about the questions
nevertheless i'm going to show them this
at the beginning of the fall and say
which kind of student do you want to be
all right but
it could be one way or the other
and the other thing is
i'm sure so what am i going to do about
this peaking thing i show the data i'm
going to try to integrate better so that
there's less of them when they come
there's less opportunities chances when
they come to the questions they're going
to go oh my god what has this got to do
with how is this related to the lecture
i just saw
and i'm planning what i've been building
in is two flavors two levels of
questions some core questions that are
really simple and you've got to get them
right you can't peek but you get two
tries
so that
the mission the
message is i got it wrong i go back and
watch the lecture i try it again
and then every lecture to get ready
there's also going to be some challenge
ones that are a little bit harder and
you can peek to at least have people
have thought about it beforehand
all right so
the
same thing so that so the
there's been some discussion already but
are there other
um
things that this raises yeah josh so one
thing in your time graph that you didn't
show is how much time you now spend in
class talking about your approach to
teaching and how people learn
and the whole better cognition thing
right
do you do that enough though it would
actually be
you know it's a news i i
i say a little at the beginning
um but i'm always afraid that when the
teacher does that it sounds like they'll
want want you know that they don't that
i'm not sure when to say those things
that they're going to be listening to me
so i
i should pitch it more but i have not
but that also might make a difference as
well
yeah in the back um just as an aside on
the previous slide but i wonder if
it might be worth talking to michael
sema and seeing what he's been doing
3091x around okay questions and how many
times we've heard people oh yeah yeah i
should um i have to make a note um
i've met him so anything different but
sort of wondered yeah yeah no i think it
turns out that those details actually
make a big because i because i think the
problems are enormously important
because they drive they should if you do
it right drive the video watching right
so how you structure them is actually
really important right yeah um let's see
right next behind it may um
you had mentioned
better integration with the video and
materials before the question that might
cause peaking but i also wonder about
integrating the peaking
and that would have been data i could
have used in real time right that if the
it turned out there isn't an immediate
way on edx to do that but actually the
right i get that analysis but if that
that would have been really useful
real-time numbers because if i've
noticed people were punting on that
question then i better make sure to ask
it in class because for whatever reason
it wasn't working right that's a great
idea right yeah and and then zion
you know how do i make sure my students
do the work they need to do before class
right and obviously quizzing them and
making that count and do you have any
other
strategies that you found successful and
making sure they really do come class
prepared
those were the only ones i think that
the the
um and i'm gonna this next time out as
an experiment with the questions that
they have to get right
we'll see how that how that flies um
i mean in the end for what it's worth
for much of the beginning it was
fantastic i mean the i would i had
expected to do quicker questions in the
canonical way you ask it
people be in their ass they mostly get
it wrong they talk to the neighbors they
mostly get it right 70 or 80 were
getting it right from the start so
i felt more or less that i was on a roll
later on things got to be more of a
struggle
yeah do you have in your class three
hundred three hundred thirty my face
zion you had a question i just forgot
i'm just wondering because we're
structuring content now for blended
learning so i was just curious as to
have you ever done face-to-face before
they were exposed to the online material
so use the face to face
as students said
lectures
basically give them the problem and give
them a reason to look into the material
that's a neat idea i have not although
it has made me think
what i've been i have to figure out how
to implement this but i was going to try
what i've been encouraging the students
to do is look at the questions first
and then watch the video right so that
you have that in your head so you know
what to look for um the problem is how
do you structure that but i'm gonna i'm
gonna encourage them to do that as a way
to to drive their video watching
a teaser
yeah you know that
that's a very interesting idea
yeah well in the pre-mooc days i had
tried that like for i had done some
computer simulation thing where they
would try something and get sort of a
weird surprising result and then we
would explain it in class and that
seemed to work fairly well
it's hard to do that for everything but
that actually turned out to work and
those ones i would grade you just have
to try and that i think it helped some
people come over
i know that the technology is not
available at x right now but do you
think it would have helped you if there
was a tracker that will show you that
each student went through the video went
through whatever material you have an
offer and then you look at the dashboard
before the class and then you can see
that make sure
everybody
went through the material whether well
or not well it's not right but they just
went through it
uh and then they know that you can know
well that's actually a really i mean so
that's actually the question that's
another issue in this this teaching
these classes that it is tricky
suppose people hadn't
what do i do i do not wish to enable or
encourage non-video watching right so
there's this chat so so that because the
way it manifests itself for me was
suppose a lot of people get the clicker
question
wrong even after i've done some
explaining
i don't want to send the message that i
don't care whether they got it right or
wrong but i also don't want to send the
message that if you guys don't come
prepared i'm going to lecture anyway so
there's this sort of tension between
because because the risk i have with
that is if everybody watches great if
not everybody watches what do i do right
and so i could say well we're canceling
class until everyone's watched the video
which would be sort of unproductive but
but it's a tension that i haven't
entirely worked out what i the way i
said it was when most people are getting
the clicker questions right i would say
all right so we're going to move on and
what i learned as i would walk into
class into the lecture hall which i'd
never done before and i realized just
how many people weren't getting it which
i never noticed i think it was always
true i just never knew
i think that there is a set of people
out there who don't expect to get it
even in that class they're going to take
some notes they're going to watch the
video and hope to digest it later
and so
i hope that they do get it later so not
everybody's even going to get it in
class and so i'm going to allow some
people to get it wrong but so but it's a
tension that i haven't i haven't figured
out exactly how to deal with it
i know what you're saying
right
attendance
so you could so my problem is what would
i do with that information if that
information was was bad do you know what
i mean and i don't and i haven't figured
out what i'd do you know tell me what
tell me what suppose suppose you were
teaching the class and no one had
watched how very people had watched the
lecture what would you what would you do
usually in saudi arabia even at
university level attendance is a
percentage of your writing
so
being consistently there enough will
affect them ten percent of your
although you know here's the thing and
this is where things get complicated
i'm sort of agnostic about whether they
watch the video or not if they can
answer those questions
then they're ready to come to class if i
pick if i do if i get the questions
right it should be that even if they
didn't need to watch the video if they
could get the questions right before
they came to class i don't care if they
watch the video or not
plus or minus i mean i think it's
probably worth their time but if they
know it so it's complicated because some
people might you wouldn't i don't want
to make them watch it because maybe they
don't need
all right
that's true that's another right or also
as a bonus or something that's right and
you you put your hand yeah i think
you're you're
i'm on the same page as you i mean
you've got to make it hurt right you've
got it however you're gonna do it you
have to make it hurt or else they won't
do it and they they won't come prepared
and everything kind of falls apart well
but remember the bottom line is coming
to class prepared not watching the
videos not you know what i mean so right
the questions
another model that um i know eric mazer
has talked a lot about when he speaks
publicly about the flipping he does at
harvard is having students help one
another on in the class right you ask
the clicker question but before you show
what the right answer is
you said you know you can show the
results right not say which one was
right and then say okay talk to your
neighbor
and try to convince your neighbor that
the answer you gave was the right one
and he said it's been amazing
to see that the students that that are
right are much more successful at
convincing their peers of the right
answer than he is yes no so that and
then you're not re-lecturing right
so that's that's another the
yes so there's a that's another
interesting solution to broadway so you
don't have to worry about and also that
makes students accountable to each other
because of people coming to if you're
constantly coming unprepared then you're
sort of a drain yeah
yeah
we had videos which were interrupted
with some multiple choice questions
and
the video just wouldn't continue if you
do not feel the same oh okay and if you
look if you're not correct it says it's
not correct but you can repeat that and
that's great so you could apply forget
the rest if you are doing it
did you have something yeah just just to
return on the question um
how to make it work
uh in the asian context
the asian culture and all wants to stay
out so
what
you usually do is like in the beginning
we have to say everybody has to be
prepared and then you do randomly walk
through the class and ask
um two weeks the students to explain
some of the content and this is how we
make it let's say
let's make
so i've tried things like that what i
what's interesting about that the sort
of cold call i i try to do that in my
class because i was where i learned a
lot about the low stakes being important
i tried to make cold calling as painless
as possible so i was never going to be
marcus what's the answer to this it was
let's talk here's a question think about
it talk to your neighbor i'm going to
pick a random name and marcus you report
for for your group right so it's not so
the thing is even then
what students would tell me is nobody
thinks they just listen desperately to
an answer that sounds right in the
neighborhood because they're because no
one wants to be the one who stands up
and says something stupid in front of
300 people and so
it turned so that was one of the things
right but my take-home message was lower
the stakes and people think more but
then you have the problem
when you lower the stakes they don't do
it right so there's a sweet spot maybe
yeah josh
what year will every
mars lecture stem class and you must
possibly
talk
i missed the very beginning what year
how in what year will every class
well you know that segues to my last
question the last thing i want to
discuss i might as well put it up so the
there are two which is the first part
there
so there's two phases there's adoption
who should do this and it's not i'm not
positive and that's a question i'll just
leave these out do the last five minutes
talking about these things i'll turn
that question back to people should it
be that every class be flipped should
some classes i don't know the answer to
that one and then which courses and then
there's an imp we started talking about
earlier was this question of
implementation
if you wanted to do it what would it
take
um and how so for example if somebody
wanted had a course a lot like mine they
want to use my materials how would they
even find them so
so that i have no more to show than just
that so the how about to josh's question
about
let me change that question slightly to
a question about
should every class be this way
oh yeah
maybe
from a full class's work of content
to any topic that needs to be moved
outside of class for whatever reason
so if you have a topic that you never
get to because you run out of time or
it's difficult and students struggle
with it in class and you end up the
whole class sort of furthers away or
it's foundational i'll have your
students know and half of them don't
they're all really good reasons
outside of the classroom um so sort of
you're involved in maybe as something
with a variety of sizes
that's a really good point because
that's another way to
to make it the people make a barrier
because you figure you have to flip your
entire class right and so for i would
add another one to the list there was a
bunch of lectures that i found really
boring to give it was kind of like
reading stuff into the record and it was
really a pleasure not to have to give
them anymore but then we end up doing
much more interactive sessions on them
that so there was like and so
yes that's that's another way to look at
it as well is to break it up about other
things
for example when we have content
providers who are providing the content
for us our guideline was 25
as 25 minimum face-to-face interaction
okay and then depending on the content
they're developing some some of them end
up doing 40 60 percent but it's quite
rough but just to give
depending on what kind of contents it's
the content that is driving it right i
mean in the end you want to get the
message across clearly new students and
maybe it's not always the best way to go
right
all right
yeah
manage these discussions so and and i
don't think you hear that very much that
it's not always about what's the
learning model say but what process
works best for the faculty members
that's absolutely true and there's two
pieces to that i think because there's
maybe if you had that faculty member
earlier it could train them differently
they might be different at this point
it's hard to change but it's also true
this because i remember um
well i worked at mit as an instructor
for outside like a head ta and there
were some lectures that their blackboard
technique was just i don't know what the
adjective for it was that their paradigm
was you wrote words on the board what
you wrote on the board was what was hard
to spell all right which is a paradigm
but it's it's insane right and so and so
the students would just go bananas
trying to take notes from them and i
thought the thing is though
this lecture was a fantastic storyteller
and i came to me that if i could if i i
probably couldn't but even if i could
get him to write more on the board he
would probably just become boring right
and so you're right you have to work
with what a person's skill set is it
shouldn't be an excuse for not changing
but it's also true that
there are things that some people are
good at and comfortable with and not
everybody's going to make this make this
fly that's absolutely true right
all right um maybe time for a couple
more another a few things
yeah early
so so the idea is students
prepared and presumably they became more
prepared
because they did more work outside yes
was there any pushback
you now invaded their out of class space
that came
so that's another really good point one
of the things i wanted to be really
careful about was not like doubling the
course load it's like oh i've moved the
content now i can teach all this new
content in class right now they do twice
as much but yeah no um
i think the there was not
my sentence is they were probably doing
very little outside of classwork uh in
the past and it was pretty unproductive
right that the students
many students would come to me and say
they were struggling they were studying
but they weren't doing well in my exams
because they didn't know how to study so
i hoped in some ways that
learning to extract information from a
video and reflecting on questions when
you're watching a video might be skills
that would help them in other classes so
i i didn't get grief about that um i
know other people have that they feel
like you've added to the workload
i don't know whether it's the culture of
umass the students tend not to complain
it's also perhaps that they were
freshmen so they hadn't didn't know what
college was yet i don't it was
interesting that i didn't get grief
about that
all right yeah last
one have a five course or a four course
vote
um you mean what i teach oh
the students they all typically science
majors take between four and five
courses
the difference is that the ivys have
four courses
most of the classes have four courses
most of the public schools have five
the official logic at the university of
maryland where i teach is that students
are supposed to put in three hours
outside of class for every hour in class
yes which means theoretically that
they're working
nine hours uh
or sorry two hours outside of class for
every hour
which means
that a three hour class plus six hours
of things it's nine hours which means
that's a 45 hour work week and that's a
hell of a work week and so
the question about the flipped class is
how much time do they have to do it now
the truth is that increasingly we find
students don't do anything they don't
they don't prepare and and it's part of
the great inflation and the dumbing down
and so on and so on but i'm wondering if
this is somehow part so i have a tiny
bit of data about that it didn't show it
but
every session i asked students to log
how long it took them to prepare for
that
and it was you know voluntary and i told
them if you don't want to give me i'd
rather have no data than bad data so if
you don't want to say or you don't
remember or whatever just put negative
one and you'll get your points for
having put a number in that box and so i
i tallied up all the non-negative one
answers and it varied over the semester
but they were spending about two hours
on average that so about 60 percent of
the students reported on any given time
and the 60 reported so they spent about
two hours for each session
which is
i guess about right um for that you're
not doing anything else
well my students there a lot of them
work because it's
but but
that doesn't include
exercises or problems the two hours is
specifically about the video about the
videos but that was basically the extent
of their homework there was nothing
there was no other homework except lab
reports all right we are have run over
so thank you everyone
you